is not because of other decisions made
oh wow I didn't see you all up there
holy mackerel don't jump
people I'm Dave Rubin it's March 21st
2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subscribe tap
that notification Bell if you have not
if you want to join us as always for the
post game show where you can correct me
if I've made any factual errors you can
ask me questions you can comment you can
say whatever you want and you can live
chat with all of our people during the
show reubenreport.locals.com uh before
we do anything you you may notice that
I've got a situation Brewing here uh
those of you that watch the show every
day and more and more of you are doing
that and we appreciate it about two
weeks ago Justin who's my oldest son
he's about seven months he's starting to
crawl he's grabbing everything and they
let he likes the beard so I let him kind
of just grab and do whatever he wants
and he's kind of poking me around anyway
these kids with the nails they're like
Freddy Krueger these kids unless you
stay on it with the nails and he slashed
me in the eye about two weeks ago and
the thing is when we do this show I'm
not big on makeup this isn't uh Cable
News Channel over here but we do a
little powder a little something just to
make sure my face is on correctly and I
think we might have infected my eye a
little bit with the powder and something
last night I was itchy it's also been
very very polleny here in the Miami area
South Florida right now especially
Southeast Florida like a lot of stuff is
blooming and growing so I've been a
little nipply and whatever I was itching
my eye my eye so yeah there's a
situation going on it is what it is I
didn't get punched nobody from the uh
you know DeSantis goons heard me say gay
out on the street and whacked me it was
not that I was I was abused by a seven
month old that's really the truth that's
where we're at I'm going to the
dermatologist today at 1 15 p.m we
thought maybe we'd delay the show today
and then we all had a meeting and we
said no Dave you must get out there the
news is so important people will accept
it they will accept that something ain't
right with your eye and then we realized
I've got the trusty uh fake newsman
glasses which does that help or hurt
what do we think guys does this help or
hurt the situation am I calling
attention to it or Connor likes them
Connor likes them guys wow I'm getting
nods from everybody's into it
wow everybody's kind of into it but is
it is it changing the
look at that Jesus I was abused by a
seven month old what a world anyway
we'll see what we can do with these but
the point of the show today is that
there is an awful lot of nonsense out
there there's an endless amount of
nonsense oh I do want to address one
other thing yesterday the show was very
Saucy it was very salty you might say
there was some language some sexual
references a few people emailed me after
and they said Dave love the show love
what you're doing uh but you know all
the this person on their knees that
person this who has a penis it's a bit
much so today I'm going to try to clean
it up a little bit I'm pretty sure all
of those emails came from Daphne
actually she just emailed me after the
show and she's like what the hell are
you doing with your life really uh
anyway today we're going to talk a
little bit about fauci we're going to
talk about the DC swamp we're going to
talk about this Trump situation we're
going to talk about the reaction uh that
DeSantis got after jumping in The Fray
and just how all of this is leading us
to just more culture wars and all of the
stuff and how do we see stay sane within
that
and I have papers here to show you that
I know what I'm doing but before we do
any of that guys I want to talk to you
about balance of nature I've got two
jars right in front of me you know
nothing is more fundamental than the
fact that fruits and vegetables are good
for you but eating all the fruits and
vegetables you need can be time
consuming and expensive which is why I
take balance of nature it gives me a
foundation of nutrition and the positive
effects of a wide variety of fruits and
vegetables in just a few seconds see why
hundreds of thousands of people take
balance of nature every day get 35 off
your preferred order when you use
discount code Dave that's 35 off your
first preferred order when you use
discount code Dave and now back to me I
wonder if I rub the veggie one on my eye
do you think that might solve some of my
problems we could try that after the
show we could ground no don't rub the
veggie one on your icon or says okay
won't do it by the way if you're in the
locals comments right now and you have
any ideas I also put a warm compress on
it this morning then I took a an ice
cold teething toy and I did that so we
warm and cold hot and cold did a little
bit of that but if you have any other
ideas before I get to the dermatologist
we are we are open and ready for
business uh okay so first off before we
do anything related to the Trump thing
and this Fiasco in New York and that
whole nonsense uh if you did not see
these clips yesterday this was really
wild PBS
public broadcast station uh has released
a new documentary about Anthony fauci
and the covid response uh now this is of
course you know basically three years
after two weeks to stop the spread and
that nonsense and it's incredible to me
that they even released this thing fauci
comes off looking so profoundly
ridiculous uh and unfactual and
nonsensical and several other adjectives
I need not say that I am amazed that
this was allowed to be released so here
is the first part we're going to show
you a couple clips of this thing it's
just absolutely incredible here is fauci
at the you know this is right at the
beginnings of kovid he's in DC he goes
to an economically depressed
neighborhood in DC DC area most of the
areas except where the super Elite live
or pretty economically depressed uh he
goes to DC with Mariel Bowser she is the
mayor of DC this is a woman who's
defunded the police done all of the
horrible stuff homelessness everywhere
the usual nonsense uh and listen to this
just watch just watch the freaking thing
foreign
so this is Anacostia
historic African-American neighborhood
in New York they have neighborhoods here
they have Wards so this is Ward eight
uh it's the typical social determinants
of Health
where they don't get good medical care
they have a high degree of HIV High
degree of coven 19.
the lowest level of vaccination
they're sort of the disenfranchised
group
that we got to reach out to so the mayor
is now with me
gonna congratulate the people who are
going to go out into the community to
try and get people vaccinated
hi Madame nice to see you real pleasure
thank you great to be us my pleasure
good
okay we're going to show you more Clips
this was the least ridiculous of all of
them but just even if you flash back to
that so he's wearing a mask in the car
for the purposes of the dock then he
meets up with the mayor in the
economically depressed area he also the
way he's driving around talking about
the area it's as if he's at like an
African safari like look at the animals
over there and this over there it's just
awful but then he walks up to the mayor
with no mask on and shakes her hand this
is in the middle of social distancing
and masking it's just all uttered
nonsense anyway then
fauci goes to the people he starts
knocking on doors to push people to get
vaccinated and I think he was frankly
shocked that some of these people were
not only pushing back but knew what they
were talking about and we did catch
fauci in at least one lie here enjoy
people in America
formation is
you know I'm not going to be lining up
taking a shot on a vaccination for
something that wasn't clear in the first
place and then you all create a shot and
miraculous time it takes years to back
well it used to take years you know how
you know how many years were invested in
this in this approach about 20 years of
science to get us to be on YouTube not
enough and nine months is definitely not
enough for nobody to be taking no
vaccination that you all came up with
the only reason I'm talking to you right
now as close as we are is that I've been
vaccinated right but if it allowed
thousands of people like you don't get
vaccinated you're going to let this
virus continue to percolate in this
country and in this world something like
the common flu then right now it's much
more serious than the flu well the flute
kills a lot of people you know how many
people died of the flu the last year I
mean not this year virtually none but
the previous year about 20 to thirty
thousand you know how many people have
died from covid-19 in the United States
000 Americans
there first off Bowser repeats the
nonsensical thing that now we knew it
was nonsensical then but now it's like
patently absurdly nonsensical that
somehow the unvaxed are going to be the
ones spreading this thing right now we
know if you are vaxed and boosted and
all that stuff you are just as likely to
get covered you are just as likely to
spread covid and in many cases I have
referenced this four billion times and
you can watch my interview with Robert
Malone uh you you will possibly he
thinks likely have a more degraded
immune system because of the vaccines
now it's interesting that fauci says
that there were no flu deaths anymore
because we pulled some numbers on flu
deaths and you tell me if something
strange is going on here in 2018 there
were 52 000 uh flu deaths in 2019 there
were 28 000. in 2020 there were 25 000
and then all of the sudden in 2021 which
is the year that this took place that
he's talking about there were only 5K
I'm starting to think that there might
be a connection between all of these
things a lot of Cova debts not as many
flu deaths could it be that the flu
deaths were counted as Cova deaths and a
whole bunch of other deaths somebody
twisted their ankle and fell down the
stairs turned out they had coveted
coveted death there you go now that
information was brought to you by the
way by statista anyway I just love this
guy I don't know who the guy is at the
top of the stairs there but like he's
got info you guys Rush this thing out at
nine months of research at fauci it's 20
years of science it's just
that regular people the reason I wanted
to show this to you and I know we're all
sort of moving past the covet thing but
we can't forget what they did to us is
that regular people didn't all go insane
lots of people did and celebrities did
and politicians did and influencers did
but just like this this normal decent
dude just trying to live his life young
guy he looks like he's I don't know
maybe in his early 30s or something and
he's just like you know basically like
hey you guys are rushing this thing out
I'm young and healthy why do we have to
be doing this uh here's part two of the
video as fauci walks away from that fine
fella
well that well the number that you all
given that died that's that's once again
that's you all's number you gonna pass
yeah definitely because when you start
talking about paying people to get
vaccinated when you start talking about
incentivizing things to get people
vaccinated there's something else going
on with that something something else
going on it is something going on you're
right but I'm glad millions of people
like me and almost everybody here didn't
get into you know what their incentive
was protecting their health and
protecting the city
y'all campaign is about fear it's about
inciting fearing people you all attack
people with fear that's what this
pandemic is it's a fear it's fear this
pandemic that's all it is
about you putting on
and stuff because he just talked to a
regular citizen it's just so gross and
and she's so condescending so
condescending and that guy's right I'd
like to find that guy's name like I'd
love to do something for that guy what
can we what can we do to help that guy
if anyone can find me his name it would
be great to do something for him because
he got it it was about fear you people
pushed this through she's lying right
like in her condescending tone you know
if you want to help other people and all
that stuff it's like no this is all just
complete nonsense uh but one more on
from this thing because this is the one
that really is just wild when when you
now know in retrospect that for three
plus years uh and we're basically three
years now and like four days off two
weeks to stop the spread that's when
they did it which by the way yesterday
was the three year anniversary of when
we got Clyde because Clyde our dog who
you guys know because we got Clyde our
previous dog had just died 16 years old
Emma she lived a great life we needed a
little time between dogs we were going
to take a little bit of a break and I
was going to be going on a book tour for
don't burn this book my first book which
obviously got canceled because of covid
um we weren't going to get a dog for a
while but then I saw this story about
how in La they were going to kill all
these dogs and I literally ran to the
shelter they would not even let me in I
basically had to push my way in and I
pretty much grabbed Clyde and they had
already signed the thing to put him down
that day and I and I grabbed him and he
saved we saved him and he's doing well
just shows you how insane this whole
there's covet out there we should kill
as many dogs as possible it's all insane
but all right here's one more on this
one and here is fauci remember this is
two plus years ago just everything he
says here is complete nonsense we now
know this all to be complete nonsense
those are the states oh my God they're
going to keep the outbreak smoldering in
the country it's so crazy I mean
they're not doing it because they say
they don't want to do it they're
Republicans they don't like to be told
what to do and we got to break that you
know unpack that how you guys doing what
vaccine
break that those people who don't like
to be told what to do those red State
people they're going to keep the disease
spreading all complete nonsense the man
is a liar he should be shamed wherever
he goes publicly don't assault him
physically but he should be shamed uh he
should be ashamed himself to go anywhere
actually and be seen in public forget
you saying something mean to him found
you you're a bad man he should actually
be ashamed to be seen in public if he
had any shame himself but I think we're
past the point of Shame he is the
science let's not forget that and those
freaking Republicans who who just we
can't bend and break are is there
anything worse than those people who
make individual choices for themselves
and think for themselves my God I can't
imagine anything worse than that you
know who might say something like that
someone who was a real authoritarian
someone who believed that you could
create a society where you could have
certain set of rules and people would
just have to exist within those rules
and they wouldn't even know what is
outside of those rules sort of like
Plato's The Cave right they they would
just know what you tell them to know and
they would not know that there is an
outside world and it would be pretty
sweet too if you could keep everybody on
a little device like this and the
government would know where they are all
the time and what they're spending their
money on all the time and where they're
going and who they're talking to and
what all their political uh thoughts are
etc etc uh that's funny because fauci's
kind of into that thing and there is a
place to far place from here called
China have you heard about this place
communist China and right now guys they
are instituting something called a
credit score the Chinese credit score
system it is happening it's particularly
happening in these 15-minute cities that
they're building in and it is completely
the direction we are moving in at least
the blue states are moving in
and that is exactly what Anthony fauci
wants he wants a bunch of people you can
break so they end up like this
a good school brings benefits but people
with low scores lose rights the cinema
names and shames people considered
untrustworthy Plastering their details
even their addresses across big screens
it's a matter of principle those people
have to be condemned those people aren't
honest so they have to pay the price
it's only right to pay your debts you
have to Blacklist those that don't
the Supreme Court has created a
blacklist for so-called bad citizens
those whose ratings have dropped to zero
on it are companies but also 23 million
people to date
among them is this journalist Liu who he
got a little too close to uncovering
corruption among high-profile party
members after being sued for defamation
by the subject of a story he'd written
he was blacklisted they only realized
when he tried to buy a train ticket and
was told he was banned from traveling
that tells me I'm still on The Blacklist
punished because he's been branded
untrustworthy by the state
once you're blacklisted you can no
longer get a bank loan start a business
buy an apartment
or even send your children to a private
school
you who is among a tiny minority of
people who have dared to criticize a
system which some are calling a digital
dictatorship
I worry because I think many people like
me will be deprived of individual
freedom
and all of us will live with
restrictions of one kind or another
does it seem like too much of a jump to
go from fauci who literally said he
wanted to break people
to what is going on in China right now
I don't think it does we are all walking
around with this device and once they
can say you can't get on that train you
can't leave your 15-minute City you
can't pay that person this you can't get
a loan at this bank or even open up an
account etc etc you can see where all
this is going they want a bunch of
mindless drone slaves they want a bunch
of non-playable characters and PCs and
you know it's funny it feels like
dystopian fiction because reality has
become dystopian fiction I'm sure many
of you watch the show Black Mirror on
Netflix do you remember the 2000 2017
episode called nosedive here's just a
little bite of it and it has literally
become reality in China and probably on
the way here
[Music]
deep
and that's one brushed suede
you want a cookie with that
found the house sounds awesome
[Music]
see you Lacy
oh saw your boy in the fire hat just now
so cute yeah he's really something
[Music]
we're not that far from it I'm sorry to
freak you out on this Tuesday but like
that's kind of where we're all headed
with this thing so you just have to link
these pieces together and as I said
yesterday look you got to walk into the
fire know what reality is no no what
seems to be coming one way or another
but then support the people that are
trying to fight these things when you
find political leaders that are actually
doing something against these things
whether that means you have to
disconnect
from some level of this in your own life
and I'm talking to myself as much as I'm
talking to anyone else right now like
this is what's happening and covid
ushered that's why the covid thing
um even though it we're past it I know
if you're watching this you've mentally
been past it for a while and and all of
that and you probably fought way more
than the average person did and maybe
they broke you to some extent and maybe
you got guilted into or forced into
getting vaccinated or you had your own
reasons or whatever but the reason it's
worth showing these things still the
reason it's worth showing that guy
standing on the top of the stairs you
know basically mocking fouchy uh and
then fauci walking away with his tail
between his legs is we have to remember
there are other good people out there
because otherwise we will end up in a
society where you will be walking around
grading everybody and degrading
everybody and what do you do when 23
million people in a society can't Bank
can't get jobs can't participate in
society the way other people can what do
you do with those people like how far
would it be before you're like I guess
we have to kill those people or put them
into camps because they're a drain on
society first off they're evil that's
why the system has kicked them out and
they're pretty evil I mean this is
basically squid game if you want to go
to another Netflix show like how far are
we from squid game or if you're a child
of the 80s how about uh running man with
Arnold Schwarzenegger anyway I'm
freaking people out this morning but at
least we kept it relatively clean
and on that note let's talk about
manscape real quick uh I've got some
breaking news for you people manscaped
now sells beard products that's right
they are once again revolutionizing
Men's Grooming with the brand new beard
hedger I mean look at my beard right now
my eye may not be right but the beard is
looking pretty solid from a beard trim
to a fresh shave the technology behind
the beard hedger Pro kit allows you to
shape your signature beard look now you
can finally use manscape products to
make your drapes match your carpet by
going to manscape.com David using Code
Dave I've got the trimmer right here and
look at this case is that is that solid
look at that thing right there
manscape.com Dave and you'll get 20 off
end free shipping it's time to tame your
Mane no one likes a weird beard so say
goodbye to all your stubble trouble with
manscapes Pro beard kit my beard has
never looked better once I started using
manscaped the pro beard kit starts with
a beard hedger which has a waterproof
titanium coated t-blade followed with a
beard shampoo conditioner oil and Balm
the pro beard kit also comes with three
free gifts a beard brush comb and
scissors to ensure your beard is ready
to impress get 20 off and free shipping
with code Dave at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code Dave and now back to me all
right so as long as we're talking about
China here and the social credit system
that in some ways
is already being put into the United
States I mean we already know that some
people can't get bank accounts that some
people can't get on social media sites
some of that has been walked back a
little bit with Elon Musk but we already
have some version of it who we associate
why we associate with certain people or
don't uh so let's move on to bigger
issues with China because another thing
that's happening right now is there
seems to be a worldwide realignment of
geopolitics and China and Russia who are
uh I guess you would say not great
countries when it comes to Human Rights
and democratic values and individual
rights and human expression they're kind
of getting in bed together and it's
partly because of what we've done here
related to Ukraine and energy and a
bunch more so president XI of China met
with Vladimir Putin Putin hasn't been
seen much lately but they met and uh
here's a little bit from their meeting I
believe this is It's either yesterday or
the day before
all right
[Music]
you a bit of their talk in just a second
but what's interesting about this is
China and Russia
their geopolitical foes of ours right it
doesn't mean you have to want to be at
war with either one of them but the fact
is they're the ethos of these countries
particularly I would say China uh is
completely anti-American their entire
system is anti-American they love
communist control and collectivism it is
the reverse of everything America is
supposed to be about the beacon that we
are of freedom to the world they are the
reverse of that
um you know I've interviewed several
people on this sort of thing I remember
Blake Masters who you guys remember he
ran for Senate in Arizona he talked
about how you know when we engaged with
China over the last decade or so we
really thought that China would see our
free market see our way of life see
freedom and China would become more like
us but unfortunately we've actually
become more like China and now because
of this Ukraine situation we've actually
started to push China and Russia
together because the entire world is
looking at alliances and going as the
United States reliable is the dollar
valuable do they have a moral Authority
anymore like maybe we have to look at
other places for Energy and Commerce etc
etc so here is President XI praising
Putin and you can clearly see this is
this is an assault on the United States
foreign
these guys are buddy buddy right now two
countries that you know we have major
issues with one of whom I would argue in
essence we are at war with Russia at
some point when you fund the war when
you fund Ukraine to the Tilt and give
them weapons and give them endless money
whether Congress has declared war
whether our president with dementia has
said we're at War at some point we're at
War so in essence we're there already
we're at War uh with Russia and China is
going to continue to encroach and by the
way they're they're watching they're
trying to figure out what they can do
with Hong Kong and Taiwan and all of
this stuff
um but let's pause on that for a moment
and think about well wait a minute what
else is different from say today than
maybe like three years ago because this
wasn't happening three years ago right
there was no Ukraine war three years ago
as you guys know Putin did take Crimea
under Obama but then didn't do anything
under that orange man and why is it that
Russia and China weren't that friendly
under orange man why is it that Russia
wasn't invading Ukraine under orange man
well it might be that orange man knew a
little something about leadership and
about uh let's say how to get countries
to kind of behave the way you roughly
wish they would Tucker Carlson was on
the full send podcast a couple days ago
and he explained just that
that Trump said he could close that in
24 hours if he wanted to do you think he
could I have no idea I mean he couldn't
build a border wall in four years so you
know there is a gap between promises and
delivery with all politicians very much
including him but I will say in Trump's
defense and maybe because he's a little
bit autistic he saw the stakes of this
like at the very beginning he's like you
don't want and this is what I do love
about Trump particularly in foreign
policy he sees the big stuff he's like
wait
you've got Russia and China they don't
trust each other you can't let them get
together they'll kick our ass and we'll
be not We're not gonna fight a war
against them one hopes but we'll
definitely be taking orders from them
definitely
look at that five years ago when
everyone's like shut up racist
he's a racist but is he wrong like what
what do you address the question shut up
racist
he's a racist all right got it but he
says if we start a war by proxy against
Russia Russia will align with China it
will be like how do you do you think
that's true or not shut up I mean they
would never address it and that's when I
was like whatever you think of trump
these people are speaking in bad faith
they're stupid they're also the ones who
got us into Iraq
do you see why the machine's always
going after Tucker too
Tucker is really good right there Tucker
did what I think anyone who is honest
would do it's what I try to do here you
know at first they're talking about the
wall Trump promised the wall he didn't
get the wall so maybe he can't do all
the things he wants nobody is above
reproach nobody is above criticism I'm
getting a lot of pushback suddenly on
the on the Twitter machine maybe because
I'm spending a little too much time here
too because I've been defending DeSantis
related to the whole Trump nonsense but
what he's saying there is okay so he got
some things right something's wrong but
he did see the big picture on this thing
that we could end up in this weird proxy
war and thus push Russia and China
closer together but it's not just that
Trump had the right instincts on this
stuff it's that our current leadership
in DC the compromise befuddled buffoon
Joe Biden who's obviously not in charge
and then the Litany of diversity hires
and half crocked swamp creatures that he
has put into positions of power either
have no idea what they're doing or are
in intentionally trying to destroy our
our alliances wreck the economy etc etc
so now we've got a couple videos for you
related to what's going on with Russia
so Pentagon press secretary John Kirby
we've shown you this guy a couple times
he's he's really I mean look Karin John
Pierre is the worst of the worst most of
the spokespeople for this Administration
are horrible this guy's just another
terrible one I mean I will give him
credit he can put a couple sentences
together he he doesn't seem as like
blatantly idiotic as Korean Jean-Pierre
cringe Jean-Pierre uh but he ain't very
good and listen
to whether there should be a ceasefire
this is CNN's Caitlin Collins asking
John Kirby if there could be a ceasefire
what are feelings about a ceasefire
would be a ceasefire meaning that we
would at least temporarily end the war
so we could all talk sort some things
out figure out what's what you'd think
we might be for that considering we're
endlessly funding this thing we got our
own problems at home here's Kirby's take
on that
tangible agreements to come out of this
Summit but and she
difficult to know Caitlyn obviously
we're not part of these discussions so
we'll see what these two leaders uh
actually come out and say at the end of
this I guess it's going to be a couple
of days here of uh of their meeting and
that agenda so we'll see uh but as you
know we've we've been very very uh
public about any concerns uh about some
sort of a ceasefire announcement right
now we all want to see peace we all want
to see this war end it could end today
if Mr Putin did the right thing but a
ceasefire called right now would
basically just ratify Russia's conquest
and give Mr Putin more time to re-equip
and retrain and uh and restart
operations at a time in a place of his
choosing so if they call for a ceasefire
you believe Ukraine should and will
reject that
yes we do and we would uh reject it as
well we think that that's an
unacceptable outcome right now uh
obviously we want the fighting to stop
we want the war to be over and as I said
it could end today if Mr Putin would do
the right thing but to call for a
ceasefire right now basically ratifies
what they've been able to grab inside
Ukraine and gives them time and space to
prepare for future operations and that's
just not going to be acceptable he
actually said the quiet part out loud
there did he cash that we would reject
it it's not just that Ukraine would
reject the ceasefire now you would think
everyone keeps telling us Ukraine is
being destroyed all of these people are
being displaced and that obviously is
true to some extent and again I believe
in the sovereignty of Nations so you
can't just invade another Nation there
should be uh repercussions for that and
it's the duty of every nation to defend
its borders as it sees fit every single
nation on Earth should do that that is
the purpose of a nation-state right uh
but that we would reject it but wait a
minute I didn't realize are we at War
aha perhaps we are as I've been saying
we actually are at War and if we are the
ones funding the war I'm pretty sure we
have a little influence when it comes to
whether Ukraine would accept a ceasefire
or not right so do you think that the
military-industrial complex here in the
United States wants to continue this or
not it obviously wants to continue it
and that's one of the reasons they were
so pissed at Trump that is just the
truth he was ending Wars we didn't have
any crazy military Adventures he was
wrapping things up but they want
continued
push on this Kirby also went on Fox News
Sunday to tell people that no we should
not have a ceasefire we have to keep
going of course and that Putin guy does
have nukes but uh you know let's not
worry about that
if coming out of this meeting there's
some sort of call for a ceasefire well
that's just going to be unacceptable
because all that's going to do Mike is
ratify Russia's Conquest to dates all
that's going to do is give Mr Putin more
time to refit retrain reman and try to
uh to to plan for for renewed offensives
at a time of his choosing we hope and
we've said this before that Mr President
XI will call and talk to president
zielinski because we believe the Chinese
need to get the Ukrainian perspective
who cares what we believe we believe
that g should just call Putin and Putin
should call zielinski and they should
just wrap this thing up that's what we
believe and we're just a bunch of nice
people so could you just do what we wish
even though we're funding the thing it's
just these people don't understand basic
diplomacy one of the things that Trump
did that was absolutely incredible I
mentioned this the other day you know he
dropped that mother of all bombs moabs
right at the beginning can you see when
did he drop that thing it was like
within months I think of his presidency
he dropped that thing and everyone was
going crazy Trump's going to start World
War Three you see what he's done and
then remember he killed the Iranian
General and people said Trump's gonna
kill start World War Three he's bananas
what and none of that happened because
what he did was he said we're a little
erratic I'm a little nuts we drop big
bombs occasionally and what that does is
it makes the enemy or the opposition go
boy we don't know what this guy's gonna
do he dropped that mother of all bombs
on April 14 2017 so pretty early on in
his presidency and then nobody messed
with us but now it's become very obvious
that she and Putin feel like ah buy it
in the United States what are they going
to do they're going to give the
ukrainians oh oh no they've got three
more tanks what are we gonna do they
don't fear the United States and you get
peace through a certain degree of fear
right speak softly and carry a big stick
somebody said that that was not a sexual
joke Daphne that was just a that was a
foreign policy statement
here's Peter Ducey from Fox asking Kirby
once again here's Kirby again if Putin
and ji fear Joe Biden
to these two leaders though do you think
that Putin and she fear President Biden
you'd have to ask them whether they fear
or they not it is not about fear it's
about President Biden advancing our
foreign policy goals around the world
it's about President Biden revitalizing
these alliances and Partnerships it's
about President Biden and what he's
doing to preserve our national security
interests around the world that's what
we're focusing meaningless dribble if
they fear you they might actually do
some of the things you want it's not
about fear it's about President Biden
making sure he can put his shoes on
which I'm pretty sure he can't even do
that
it just endlessly every that's what I'm
trying to show you guys at every level
of this government whether I'm showing
you things from Karin Jean-Pierre or
we're showing you Janet Yellen or we're
showing you John Kirby or we're showing
you mayorkis at the border every single
one of these people is unqualified to do
their job so we'll get into the 20 24
thing in a second but whether you like
Trump or you like DeSantis or you like
Nikki Haley or vivec you must vote for
these people you must support these
people we have to remove this
Administration that is actively
destroying our country basically at
every possible turn Ducey continued here
he asked uh Kirby again about Putin and
G and do they even care about what Biden
thinks
tough he tried to pressure Putin and she
uh to act right or risk their standing
on the world stage does he see now that
they don't care
I think if you ask a lot of Russians
they certainly care I mean this their
economy is is uh barely being propped up
by some pretty radical measures by by Mr
Putin their military has uh been uh
roundly embarrassed inside Ukraine
um and they continue to lose uh ground
there
the Russian economy is barely being
propped up by radical measures how's our
economy doing we're printing money like
drunken sailors
the drunken Sailors print money
not I don't know what they do those
drugs or they I guess they bury treasure
and then they lose the treasure and then
they get scurvy and the whole situation
but we had a bank run last week we
bailed out our banks last week so do you
think we're doing so great here but the
Russians are really freaking out it's
just such it's it's a shell game right
never never keep your eye on the ball
just watch the shells moving and moving
and moving so let's go back to Trump for
a second because Trump uh did not cause
Wars while he was President as Tucker
said he did some erratic things so that
people wondered and he saw the big
picture he saw the Blue Sky you don't
want to take two big countries that you
have major issues with and force them
together which is literally what is
happening today uh so here's Trump a
couple days ago revealing uh how he
would end the war in a day
before I arrive at the Oval Office
shortly after I win the presidency I
will have the disastrous war between
Russia and Ukraine settled it'll take 24
hours
if it's not done before then
what a shame that is it's a horrible
thing taking place I could get that
thing settled it would have never
happened if I were president zero chance
and even the Democrats admit that
even the Democrats say now if Trump were
president and
President Putin knows could do we used
to talk about as they can't do it you're
not going to do that
I mean you can't really argue with that
look can Trump could Trump if he was
president and this thing in 24 hours
that's probably a little bit of
hyperbole but the simple truth is it did
not happen under his watch and I what he
said there Putin and I used to talk
about this and basically you're not
going to do this right now you don't
know what we are going to do but nobody
fears the United States and nobody
respects Biden it really is as simple as
that you don't have to really understand
everything about geopolitics to just
understand basic stuff about strength
and weakness and that really is what it
is but the system does not like Donald
Trump obviously there is this nonsense
you know supposedly today was the day he
was going to be arrested by this New
York City D.A the Soros funded D.A Alvin
Bragg you know even on Friday when this
thing broke we had a couple people over
for dinner and I was telling everyone
like I don't think he's getting arrested
on Tuesday that's why I also didn't
think that the santis nor anyone else
had to immediately rush to his defense
because it sort of felt like he was just
putting a trial balloon out there like
I'm just gonna say this crazy thing and
let's see how everyone reacts and of
course everyone fell for the bait and
everyone's fighting you didn't say this
then and Trump did this or murder
everyone's fighting about everything but
the point is
they are obviously Alvin Bragg New York
City D.A the machine around him the DNC
they are obviously trying to do
everything they are throwing that
freaking kitchen sink off the roof
hoping that it hits Donald Trump on the
head 12 floors down that's what they're
going for because they fear Him and they
should fear Him they should also fear
DeSantis they should fear everybody at
this point because they're a bunch of
incompetent buffoons but harm me Dylan
you guys know Harmony she ran for head
of the RNC did not work out but she's
also a spectacular First Amendment
lawyer and an endless Fighter for free
speech and for actual due process and
things like that that we used to care
about she went on Tucker last night to
talk about this this absolute farce of
an investigation into Trump coming out
of New York City
prosecution if it comes through is
absolutely baseless it's ludicrous it
has been rejected not only by the FEC as
you mentioned but also by federal
prosecutors and also by prior
prosecutors of New York state so this is
really well past its sell by date a it
it does not fly in court it is frivolous
and what you are looking at really
Tucker is the mother of all election
interference here like you said in your
lead into this
doing everything possible to make sure
that Trump either does not run or is too
distracted to run or can't raise funds
to run Etc et cetera because they they
hate him they fear Him whatever you want
to call it at this point with Trump now
uh I would say next to that sort of
right side by side with that is that
something good actually is happening
with the Republicans right now what have
I been saying since the midterms the
Republicans now have a chance right so
you got the house McCarthy is the leader
you can start doing the correct hearings
which they're starting to do we're
finding out more information about
collusion between the government and big
Tech related to free speech they
immediately got rid of those they
defunded that 87 000 IRS agents like
they're doing some good things they seem
to be fighting the right fights and
Kevin McCarthy who a lot of people are
very critical of Kevin McCarthy I'm
going to be interviewing him in a couple
days uh we're doing it next week right
that's next week yeah next week I'm
going to DC to interview him with a live
audience we're taking 100 locals
community members over to DC and we're
doing that and then a couple other
things if you're in the locals Community
you probably know what we're doing if
you're not sorry you don't know but I
gave you a little taste right there uh
McCarthy is uh is stepping up and listen
to his statement on what's going on with
Trump right now
it doesn't matter what side of the issue
you're on it doesn't matter if this was
President Trump or if this was a
Democrat
it should be equal justice in America
and stop going after people because you
have political differences I don't think
people should protest this no and I I
think president Trump if you talk to him
he doesn't believe that either I mean I
think I think the thing that you may
misinterpret when the when President
Trump talks
when someone says that they can protest
he would probably be referring to my
tweet educate people about what's going
on he's not talking in a harmful way and
nobody should nobody should harm one
another
see the media was trying to do there was
lay the trap again because Trump on
Truth social put out there that you know
people should protest in honor of this
or in in protest of this you know this
nonsensical farce
you could see the way the MSNBC clowns
and the rest of the media ah you see
he's trying to get people out there
again January 6th again here we go of
course nothing has happened and he
didn't say violently protest and he
didn't say burn anything down or shoot
anybody or anything else but the point
of all of this is that this is all
leading to 24 right like that's what
this is all about obviously they don't
want Trump they don't want the Santa's
either and they'll deal with as I said
they they're going to call uh DeSantis
Trump with a calculator once they figure
out how to get rid of trump so like
there's a Litany of things that these
people can do and there's almost no
bottom to that to that hole where they
will always go to to just do horrible
things but a lot of it could backfire
you know just remember like in America
anything can happen as I learned on
Election night in 2016 or as many of us
learned when Trump became president
anything can still happen in America and
uh Andrew Clavin you guys know Andrew
Clavin from the daily wire uh he was the
one that really sort of got that going
in my mind that night because on that
night election night although Hillary
didn't concede till the next day if you
remember what he said was look it looks
like the thing that everyone said
couldn't happen just happened that's a
beautiful thing in America so even
though it feels like all the screws are
being turned against us right now and we
can talk about Chinese social credit
system and we could see this alliance
between China and Russia and the
nonsense of ESG and all of the woke
stuff so it feels like there's this like
the walls are closing in on us right
they're always telling us the walls are
closing in on Trump but it feels like
they're closing on us there's always a
chance there's always a chance and I
think a lot of people see that Elon Musk
responding to Viva Frey you guys know
Viva Frey we've had him on the show a
bunch of times Aviva tweeted out if this
happens it will be the beginning of
Trump's re-election and he's referring
to this this prosecution and if they
were to actually arrest and fingerprint
Trump and all that Elon responded and
said if this happens Trump will be
re-elected in a landslide Victory okay
so Elon Musk gets it the this is what
these weirdos do they Butterfly Effect
this entire thing right like uh you they
make these things bigger it's just like
let let Trump run and let the
Republicans decide is is this the future
of the Republican party is DeSantis the
future whatever it might be but instead
they just want to pile on and endless
the vindictive vindictiveness and the
endlessness uh it just does not stop but
what I'm very happy about all of this
being said is there is going to be a
wide swath of Republicans who are going
to be pretty decent you may not like
this one because a foreign policy you
may not like that one because they
didn't say what you wanted to say the
day they said it and you may have
loyalty to this guy or whatever else it
is but right now Trump DeSantis again we
don't even know if DeSantis is running
but the point is Trump DeSantis Vivek
Nikki Haley it sounds like Pompeo is
going to get in Tim Scott might get in
like this is a much better cast of
characters than the Democrats put up
last time and they're going to have to
battle out it's gonna get nasty some of
you will probably turn on me I'll turn
on you we'll see what happens here
people will take out my other eye it's
going to be a blood bat
but the point is there are good people
involved whether you agree with them 100
and one of the things that I'm going to
try to do is interview every single
candidate that announces now it's
obviously going to be a bunch of
Republicans but if some Democrats get
involved too to primary Biden I'll try
to interview them as well the fir and I
want to do these all absolutely in
person not on the phone not in Skype we
will go to people they can come to us
whatever it is so we've been reaching
out to all the campaigns the first
person that we sat down with uh was
Nikki Haley just a couple days ago and
here she is talking about her campaign
you know I mean look I'm a decisive
person I didn't need to wait I didn't
need to wait to see who else was going
to get in I didn't need to wait or worry
about anything else I think if you're
going to do this you have to do it
because you know this is what you want
and you know this is what you think you
can do for the country and so we were
ready and you know it's been a month and
it's been a whirlwind but we're working
and all is good
right there's going to be a bunch of
decent candidates people who know what
time it is people who know how to tie
their shoes and people who have done
good things in the past Nikki ran a
really successful uh run as governor of
South Carolina she was extremely good as
Trump's U.S ambassador to the U.N and
hopefully we just get more and more of
these people actually tomorrow I think
I'm going to be the first guest on Vivek
ramaswami's uh new podcast and he's
called me yesterday and he said let's
just talk about stuff stuff we agree on
stuff we disagree on he said go as hard
as on me as you want and let's see what
happens so the more of that the better
or not fighting the best of the best
guys that really is the truth and once
again I was not punched by a DeSantis
goon on the street for saying gay I have
some sort of mild infection in my left
eye and we're going to deal with it at 1
15 at the local dermatologist and
speaking of local if you want to join us
in about 36 seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com we have an IOS
and Android app you can chat with me
live let's do it uh by the way that
interview with Nikki Haley part one is
up on YouTube and Rumble right now the
full thing is up already at locals we
leave you with Kamala Harris and March
Madness listen to this Wizard and I'll
see everybody else in just a moment
thanks guys
is so good
play it hard you played to the very last
second
you made all us bison so so proud
it showed the world
who bison are
you know I was at Howard back in the day
where we were just happy that there was
a game
much less getting to this place
right and I see bison literally all over
the world and we've been talking about
you this team
you make us so proud so I know you may
not be feeling great right now okay but
Know Who You Are
you are excellent
[Music]